die radikalisierung kann durch einen
beschluss aus niedersachsen noch mehr
angefeuert werden dort soll ab kommendem
jahr die 2g regel auch für kinder und
jugendliche ab zwölf jahren gelten wie
ist das zu bewerten wie ist das aus
medizinischer sicht vor allem zu sehen
das wollen wir jetzt von dr uwe büsching
erfahren er ist kinderarzt in bielefeld
hallo herr dr büsching ja hallo ja was
denken sie über die 2g regelungen für
kinder ab 12 jahren
also ich grundsätzlich bin der meinung
dass die kinder genauso geimpft werden
sollten wie die erwachsenen bei den
erwachsenen laufen wir jetzt
habt ihr gehört haben in amerika aus
mehreren kanälen auch die situation hin
dass wir bei den erwachsenen booster
müssen
meine persönliche meinung lieber nach
vier oder fünf monaten der mit sechs
monaten aber spätestens nach sechs
monaten muss die post ab weil
andernfalls die
wirkung der impfung die dann ein halbes
jahr länger zurückliegt deutlich
nachlässt und dann könnten nicht die
kinder nur dafür erhalten dass wir aus
dieser von dem ihm verdanken wir
irgendwann mal raus müssen aber die
eltern sind natürlich verunsichert die
ständige impfkommission hat lange
gebraucht um die empfehlung
auszusprechen
ihr chef herr mertens hat selber gesagt
er persönlich würde seine kinder nicht
impfen lassen was ist ihr rat in dieser
schwierigen situation für die eltern
also herr mertens hat diesen diese
informationen gegeben zum zu der impfung
von fünf bis elfjährigen wir reden aber
doch jetzt über die 12 12 gegen und 2g
und nicht für die fünf- bis elfjährigen
zu zweit gehen und von daher ist mein
persönlicher rat für die jüngeren sich
strikt an die stiko zu halten ich würde
mal sagen 95 prozent meiner frau gesagt
wir orientieren und seit 25 jahren
erfolgreichen an den vorgaben der stiko
und das möchten wir auch jetzt nicht
ändern und
von daher ist das eher positiv wenn die
stiko zurückhaltend ist um zu zeigen sie
sind vorsichtig was neue impfstoffe
betrifft ja merken seid ja auch ganz
klar gesetzt triebes dessen wegen nicht
weil die
datenlage zu den impfstoff
nebenwirkungen in der gruppe 5 bis 11
nach nicht ausreichend sind aber das
muss man da rein interpretieren hatte
offensichtlich genügend druck bekommen
jetzt doch zumindest für risikokinder
und für die kinder deren eltern eine
impfung wünschen dann doch freizugeben
es ist ja dennoch so dass für 2g ab 12
jahren eine indirekte impfpflicht für
kinder und jugendliche bedeutet ist das
wirklich okay sofort zu gehen
welche die die alternative wäre schule
schießen und ich denke ich denke wir
haben bei der pandemie nicht die
möglichkeit etwas tolles aus zu
behinderten wir haben nun die
möglichkeit zwischen zwei übel zu wählen
und ich finde schulschließung wäre ein
größeres übel als eine kleine quasi
impfpflicht durch die hintertür wir
haben in der altersgruppe 12 bis 15 auf
der einen seite keine möglich schweren
erkrankungen wir haben auf der anderen
seite in der altersgruppe 12
18 keine wirklichen ernstzunehmende
nebenwirkungen durch die impfung bisher
erlebt dass die stiko am anfang zu
zögerlich war war wieder gekauft die
aussage uns fehlen im aktuellen
situation noch die daten um wirklich
offen und ehrlich sagen zu können das
ist eine sinnvolle entscheidung deswegen
war die empfehlung der ema und fünf
wochen vor der empfehlung der stiko
stichworte
schulschließungen jetzt liegt auch die
forderungen auf dem tisch dass ich
lehrer und erzieher impfen lassen
sollten als er in pflicht für diejenigen
die mit den schülern jeden tag zu tun
haben würden sie das unterstützen
ja das würde ich unterstützen weil ich
der persönliche meinung denn wir haben
alle zusammen als individuum auch für
diesen staat eine verantwortung und wir
haben eben schon über das thema im
verweigerer geredet ich kann das nicht
verstehen wenn ich meine kolleginnen und
kollegen in den kliniken erlebe bin ich
weiter meine tochter erlebe die als
krankenschwester in einem krankenhaus
arbeitet dann kann ich nicht verstehen
warum menschen sagt ich fühle mich hier
drangsaliert das einzige problem was ich
nachempfinden kann es in den letzten im
letzten jahr politik sich zu sehr in dem
in die aufgabe der ärzteschaft
eingemischt hat und das eigentlich auch
das heute beibehält das ist eine kritik
der ärzteschaft jetzt nicht von mir
persönlich kommt sondern generell artist
und die profis impfen waren bis vor
anderthalb jahren die ärzte und nun auf
einmal ist alles anders ist das macht
eben auch konflikte und das führt dann
auch dazu dass aktuell viele menschen
sagen hier wird in politisch
durchgesetzt und nicht medizinisch
sinnvoll die einschätzung von dr uwe
büsching kinderarzt aus bielefeld vielen
dank dafür